Dear friends of VisualPolitik, I think most
of you will agree: achieving a strong democracy
isn’t easy.
In our world, there are many democracies,
but unfortunately, few quality ones.
Obviously when I speak of quality I mean a
democratic system that respects individual
freedom, legal security, political plurality...
things like that.
Well, when it comes down to it, there's one
basic principle that's essential for any quality
democracy.
And isn’t usually liked by most politicians
at all.
I’m talking about alternation; something
that’s essential in order to stop any single
person or group of people from essentially
taking over government institutions.
It’s precisely due to this concern that
many countries have a limitation of mandates.
“Nothing is as dangerous as allowing the
same citizen to stay in power for a long time.
The people get used to obeying him and him
to leading them, from here, usurpation and
tyranny emerge.”
Simón Bolívar)
Folks, trying to prevent political alternation
at any cost isn’t new, or rare, throughout
the world.
And in recent years, in one way or another,
Latin America has been plagued with politicians
who’ve managed to retain power at all costs.
Politicians like Daniel Ortega in Nicaragua,
Juan Orlando Hernández in Honduras and Nicolás
Maduro in Venezuela.
Now, the latest person to join this list seems
to be the Bolivian President, Evo Morales.
And the question many of you are currently
asking is, is Bolivian democracy in danger?
What’s happening?
Why is Evo Morales’s candidacy so controversial?
Listen up.
(PROMISES AND AN ADDICTION TO POWER)
On January 22nd 2006, with more than 50% of
the vote, Evo Morales became the first indigenous
president in the 193 years since Bolivia’s
independence.
His arrival to power meant the end of political
exclusion for most of Bolivian society.
In fact, from a historical perspective, I
think Evo’s rise to power was inevitable.
But with his leftist speech against Yankee
imperialism and in favor of the political
participation of indigenous peoples and the
nationalization of natural resources, Evo
Morales set out to lead a transformation in
the country, a transformation that had wide
popular support.
To achieve his objectives, the Bolivian government
opted for something that has become very fashionable
in Latin America in recent years: Changing
the Constitution!
Something that, by the way, also gained a
lot of popular support, as election after
election, Evo Morales swept the polls.
But... let's go back to the Constitution,
to Evo Morales’ own Constitution.
This is what his article 168 said.
“The State’s President or Vice President
mandate lasts for 5 years and they can be
re-elected only once on a continuous basis.”
Article 168 of the Bolivian Constitution)
It's clear, right?
On a continuous basis, a person can only exercise
the office of president for two terms.
And each term lasts 5 years.
Thus, as Evo ran for re-election in 2009,
his time in government should’ve ended in
2014, right?
Basic mathematics.
But, but... wait... something doesn’t fit.
It’s the year 2018, Evo Morales is still
in power and is going to run for re-election
in the 2019 elections.
So, what the hell happened?
Listen up.
(THE INDEFINITE REELECTION)
Folks, this is the story of how a man fell
in love with Power.
Let's see, Evo’s Constitution established
alternation as a necessary principle for democracy
to work.
But... as soon as the new Constitution was
approved, problems began.
Evo said ok, the previous mandate didn’t
count because it happened under a different
Constitution... so just as the Bolivian state
had been re-founded they needed to reset the
score to zero.
Yeah, it’s a bit absurd.
Alternation isn’t a punishment, but a way
of preventing a person from being in power
for too long.
And if you believe in it and introduce it
into the Constitution that you yourself have
promoted... well you’ll need to respect
it, right?
Well…
No.
In fact, Evo Morales managed to get a positive
ruling from the Constitutional Court on a
very controversial case.
According to the court, Evo had been the President
of Bolivia, but now he wanted to be the president
of the Plurinational State of Bolivia, which
isn’t the same, so he could govern for two
consecutive terms.
See the difference?
Overnight Bolivia, the Bolivia that had always
existed, had disappeared.
This explains why Evo ran in the 2009 elections
and for re-election in 2014.
But no, of course, he wouldn’t be able to
run again.
And actually, Evo himself has said this plenty
of times.
He said that in 2019 he’d leave the world
of politics to open his own restaurant.
But... just a second… because yes, the restaurant
sounds great, but staying in power?
Folks, that sounded a lot better to Evo.
So in 2015, just one year after his re-election,
deputies related to the President, presented
a proposal to reform the Constitution.
The newly approved Constitution!
Can you guess what for?
So that both the president and vice-president
could be reelected two times, that is, so
that Evo can run again in 2019.
However, this time the shot backfired.
The reform did go ahead in Parliament... but
it also had to be approved by referendum...
and there, surprisingly, Evo lost.
Do you agree with the reform of article 168
of the Political Constitution of the State
so that the President and Vice President of
the State can be reelected twice in a continuous
way?)
The question of the 2016 constitutional referendum)
The question was clear and the answers even
more so: Yes or No.
Yes or no to reelection.
And the Bolivians said No,
But what do you think Evo Morales did?
Did he accept the result of the referendum
and the Constitution that he himself had embraced
and promoted?
Well... obviously not.
The indigenous leader, the politician who
was going to return the sovereignty to the
people, suddenly came to say: alright, let’s
see… the people have been manipulated...
so they don’t really need to be taken into
account.
However, in spite of everything, he once again
promised to respect the results.
Now, this time, was he serious or not?
Well…
No, he wasn’t.
See, taking advantage of his control over
the institutions – which is precisely what
alternation tries to avoid – Evo managed
to do something unheard of:
The “Plurinational Constitutional Court”,
the body tasked with interpreting fundamental
rule, in its 84/2017 ruling, declared parts
of the Constitution itself as invalid.
To justify such a measure, they used International
Law, and the Constitutional Court devoted
itself to assessing and interpreting the American
Convention on Human Rights, the Inter-American
Court Jurisprudence... everything but the
National Constitution itself.
In the end, the result of this entire experiment
was that the articles that bothered Evo Morales,
from his own Constitution, were de facto repealed
and it was ruled, listen to this, that indefinite
re-elections were a human right.
Because limiting mandates and demanding alternation
is an attempt to undermine human rights.
No, in the end, Evo will even get Álvaro
Uribe to support his regime.
In short, let’s get serious... because it’s
no joke that a politician can do and undo
whatever he pleases with his country’s institutions.
That is dangerous, very dangerous.
The fact is that in Bolivia, Article 168 hasn’t
been repealed or modified.
What happened is that now the Bolivian Constitution
has parts that are upheld and others that
aren’t.
All of this has unleashed protests against
Evo Morales’s anti-democratic drift, both
inside and outside of the country.
Of course, in the face of such a spectacle,
several members of the Electoral Tribunal
have resigned, and have been replaced by people
close to Evo Morales’s own party.
Thus, finally on December 4th, 2018, this
body approved Evo Morales’s candidacy to
the presidency and Álvaro Garcia Linera to
the Vice Presidency.
“Nothing is as dangerous as allowing the
same citizen to stay in power for a long time.
The people get used to obeying him and him
to leading them, from here, usurpation and
tyranny emerge.”
Simón Bolívar)
But... just a second.
I know what some of you may be thinking...
But Simon, there will still be elections...
if the Bolivians don’t want him then they
shouldn’t vote for him, right?
Well, folks, there are two problems with this:
First, a democracy can never, ever consist
of tyranny of the majority over the minority.
Institutions need to be respected and their
mechanisms must exist to prevent a politician
from clinging to power through the use of
techniques such as clientelistic voting, dependence
on the government, control of the media or
simple coercion.
The second problem has a lot to do with the
obsession with power that Evo Morales has
shown.
In other words: how far are Evo Morales and
his party, the Movement to Socialism, willing
to go to stay in power?
Evo lost the Referendum and is still running.
He’s moved heaven and earth to be a candidate
again.
So now the question is, will he be willing
to lose the elections or will he opt instead
for the strategy of winning at any cost?
I’m referring to the strategy that has kept
people like Nicolás Maduro, Daniel Ortega
and Juan Orlando Hernández in power.
Come on, the usual move.
This is the question that many are asking
themselves in Bolivia.
And watch out, because what Evo Morales has
achieved, besides being the Bolivian politician
who’s been in power the longest, is getting
this country’s institutions to act at his
will.
Bolivians declare Evo Morales as “the new
dictator”.
More than 150 civil organizations agreed to
declare Evo Morales as a dictator and determined
an activities agenda in “defense of democracy”.
PanamPost)
Anyways, folks, here at VisualPolitik we’ll
be very, very attentive to whatever may come.
So I really hope you enjoyed this video, please
hit like if you did, and don’t forget to
subscribe for brand new videos.
Don’t forget to check out our friends at
the Reconsider Media Podcast - they provided
the vocals in this episode that were not mine.
Also, this channel is possible because of
Patreon, and our patrons on that platform.
Please consider joining them and supporting
our mission of providing independent political
coverage.
And as always, I’ll see you in the next
video.